[Musique]
bonsoir le monde d'après covit vous
souvenez c'était il ya un an beaucoup
imaginent et changer de société en fait
le gouvernement est entourant toujours
en train de gérer la crise au fil des
jours aujourd'hui le nombre de personnes
en réalisation dépasse même le niveau de
la deuxième vague la reprise d'une vie
normale va dépendre probablement de
vaccination mais les vaccins tarder à
arriver et dans ce contexte le
gouvernement va-t-il pouvoir relancer
les réformes qui sont au point mort et
qui devaient être les marqueurs du
quinquennat macron je pense notamment à
l'assurance chômage et aux retraites
pour l'instant en tout cas
il ya d'autres priorités en particulier
relancer l'économie on va parler de tout
ça ce soir avec votre invité amélie de
montchanin bonsoir vous êtes ministre de
la fonction et de la transformation
publique us à la fin
merci cet invité deux auditions
publiques sur lcp public sénat avec le
figaro nous sommes ensemble pendant une
heure d'abord une question qui est dans
toutes les têtes
les écoles vont elles fermées et la
tendance du côté du gouvernement quelle
information vous avez alors moi je veux
dire on n'est pas l'envoyer dans une
série télévisée on n'est pas là dans le
suspense on est face à une situation qui
est très grave qu'il ya des vies en jeu
et notre méthode depuis le départ c'est
d'être transparent sur la situation et
d'être transparent sur les décisions
transparence sur la situation tous les
jours nous rendons publics l'ensemble
des informations dont nous disposons que
ce soit sur la capacité hospitalière sur
les tests sur la situation à laquelle se
trouve le pays
transparent sur les décisions nous
sommes aussi chaque semaine chaque
semaine nous avons conseil de défense
concédé ministres sont deux décisions
qui sont prises et chaque semaine nous
nous adaptons il ya un mot je crois
qu'ils aient ressortait fortement dans
le centre-ville
les déclarations du président ce
week-end sur le fait qu'ils l'assument
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que nous savons que nous sommes en
responsabilité que nous avons à nous
adapter en permanence à faire des choix
vous trouvez la ligne de crête comment
protéger
évidemment la santé des français comment
protéger alors services hospitaliers
comment protéger aussi notre économie
dit qu'il vous reposer la question
différemment
est-ce qu emmanuel macron pourrait
annoncer des mesures décisives cette
semaine est ce qu'on est dans une
semaine décisive
on est chaque semaine dans une semaine
décisive chaque semaine nous avons à
faire des choix en responsabilité nous
avons aussi à nous adapter
avec quelques jours elle a merkel a dit
voilà proposé après un très long
confinement puis un début de
déconfinement que week-end de pâques
soit très fortement contrôlé en
allemagne elle s'est ensuite elle est
revenue sur sa décision disant voilà
j'ai annoncé quelque chose auquel je
vais revenir
j'ajouterai même elle s'est excusée mais
fait mal mercredi pas de mea culpa lui
il ya quand même une différence entre
les 2 nancy on crie je peux vous dire je
le sois un gouvernement qui quand les
choses ne partent pas droit je pense à
cette texture d'attestation quatre
heures après il ya plus à des stations
que c'est une chose angela merkel s'est
excusé c'est bien qu une dirigeante
s'excuse comme ça mais c'est très bien
que nous soyons lucides et surtout
extrêmement transparent et des français
sur nos responsabilités moi je fais
partie d'un gouvernement qui
effectivement assume que nous prenons la
décision que nous ne rejetons pas la
faute sur d'autres notamment comme
parfois c'est sous le cas sur les hauts
fonctionnaires son administration nous
prenons des décisions si la mise en
oeuvre de nos décisions ne se passe pas
comme nous n'attendons nous nous
adaptons très vite si un certain nombre
de choix se révèle après quelques jours
quelques semaines plus adapté la
situation à castres nous adaptons très
vite mais pas d' excuses devant les
français n'y a pas de raison 11h00 il
n'y a pas de raison de qui me guide
c'est que nous ayons d'abord beaucoup
d'humidité sept crimes il était plutôt
qu'exclut mais cette crise est inédite
il n'y a pas un plan caché de gestion du
kobe dans un tiroir qu'on aurait oublié
d'ouvrir c'est aussi beaucoup de
responsabilités nous parlons d'un jeu
extrêmement grave nous parlons de la vie
de millions de français de milliers de
français et nous parlons aussi la santé
économique d'un pays qui est un
véritable enjeu
alors on va parler aux stills enfin la
proportionnalité nous avons à chaque
moment à prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent en cherchant tout en
équilibre on va parler aussi de lance de
ce que vous gérez notamment la fonction
publique puisque c'est votre
portefeuille et ce soir sur le plateau
avec moi président bush et de lcp
bonsoir brigitte 21-27 radmin de public
sénat bonsoir top ans après mes manches
alors effectivement vous êtes ministre
de la fonction publique l'état appelle
beaucoup aujourd'hui à faire plus de
télétravail quelle est la proportion de
télétravail aujourd'hui dans la fonction
publique est ce que ça a progressé
depuis le premier confinement corse a
énormément progressé depuis le premier
confinement je vous rappelle que dans le
premier confinement 30 % des agents
publics de l'état étaient au chômage
technique au chômage partiel et donc on
nous avions d'ailleurs des guichets de
services publics étaient fermés
moi je suis arrivé dans ce ministère au
mois de juillet la décision que j'ai
prise très fortement c'était de nous
assurer qu'eux
quoi qu'il arrive nous puissions
maintenir des services publics de
qualité ouvert adaptées aussi à ces
contraintes qui pèsent sur la vie des
français et ce que nous devons donc
accompagné alors aujourd'hui engagés
pour la suite pour pour aujourd'hui je
m'y engage très fortement
j'ai à dire d'ailleurs à tous les
français quoi qu'il arrive les services
publics seront maintenus nous laisserons
les guichets ouverts parfois ils sont
ouverts avec des alternatives par
téléphone vous l'avez vu aujourd'hui
encore à créteil le présent la
république montre que nous nous adaptons
aussi un service public nous appelons
les plus fragiles que ce soit bien sûr
pour la vaccination
autre exemple les caisses d'allocations
familiales appelle directement les
familles les plus isolées
l'assurance vieillesse appellent les
retraités les plus vénales collectif
combien de vue d'un tel prix au
télétravail
oui aujourd'hui ce qu'on avait beaucoup
progressé puisque nous avions 40 % des
agents de l'état hors enseignants et
forces de l'ordre qui par définition
n'ont pas des métiers télétravail à bhl
qui télétravaillent au mois de janvier
aujourd'hui nous sommes à plus de 56 %
57 % la semaine dernière deux personnes
qui ont télétravail et dans l'état sait
combien de jours par semaine parce que
on est aujourd'hui dans les
administrations centrales
on peut me sers parisien à plus de 75%
de télétravail la moitié se faisant sur
quatre ou cinq jours le télétravail de
télétravail dans les services
déconcentrés donc dans les préfectures
et les sous préfectures
on est autour de 45% de télétravail et
là on est plutôt à un tiers du
télétravail qui se fait sur quatre ou
cinq jours et nous allons nous aligner
sur ce que vous demandez aux privés
aujourd'hui quand on est totalement
alignée il n'y a pas de guerre n'y a pas
de conflit entre le public et le privé
deux jours sur sac dans les entreprises
qu'on demande
on n ou non demande quatre jours voire
cinq jours à toutes les personnes
certaines personnes demandent à revenir
un jour par semaine et c'est normal
parce que on a des personnes qui se sont
parfois isolés mon ans je sais que les
territoires notamment les dix neuf
territoires qui sont en mesures
renforcées soit accompagnée pour que
service par service bureau par bureau
administration par administration on
augmente le nombre de personnes qui
travaillent et aussi qu'on augmente le
nombre de jours ma méthode c'est là
aussi beaucoup transparence énormément
de pilotage cibler un dialogue social
renforcé je vous les syndicats tous les
quinze jours me fonder remontée précise
et depuis le mois de janvier cette
méthode fonctionne
est-ce que entre parenthèses est ce que
le nombre de capco vidéo augmente chez
les fonctionnaires
comme partout ailleurs ou plus
alors aujourd'hui par pour des raisons
de secret médical je n'ai pas accès vous
voyez un listing de fonctionnaires qui
sont positifs en revanche je suis le
nombre d'agents qui sont dans
l'incapacité de travailler parce que
notamment ils seraient vulnérables
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 0 5 % d'agents
qui sont comme on dit en autorisations
spéciales d'absence c'était 30% prendre
le premier confinement ce que je vais
vous dire là c'est que nous avons
beaucoup appris nous sommes beaucoup
adapté et aujourd'hui je peux parce que
et je fais un pilotage personnel avec
l'ensemble des grands directeurs de tous
les services publics assurer que nous
maintiendrons les services publics
ouverts parce que nous ne pouvons pas
demander aux français dans avec une
circonstance aussi difficile de ne pas
avoir à leur côté un service public qui
fonctionne
il fonctionne de manière différente mais
il est toujours là il ya toujours
quelqu'un pour etienne on parlait à
l'instant de la vaccination emmanuel
macron veut accélérer sur la vaccination
est ce que vous avez identifié des
publics prioritaires dans la fonction
publique
premier objectif déjà c'est de vacciner
toutes les personnes qui sont les plus à
risque de développer des formes graves
d'aller malheureusement réanimation et
je vois pas lequel est en réanimation ça
veut dire beaucoup trop de cas soient
décédés soit avoir des séquelles très
longue
notre premier objectif ce sont les
personnes les plus âgées et les
personnes qui ont des facteurs de risque
comme uni de comorbidité dans ces
personnes qui ont des comorbidités vous
avec des agents publics qui ont du
diabète qui ont l'hypertension donc déjà
ses agents publics a c'est sûr la
condition médicale que nous les
vaccinaux en priorité c'est à peu près
de 15 millions personnes ce premier
cercle qui n'a une priorité vous savez
qu'on a fixés 10 millions de vaccinés
mi-avril 20 millions ensuite oui mais
effectivement il ya eu ensuite des
personnes qui sur leurs pratiques
professionnelles peuvent être exposés de
manière plus directe au virus et nous
avons annoncé avec le présent la
république que appartement ou ceux qui
étaient les plus à risque de développer
les formes graves
d'autres professions je tiens à dire
c'est l'ensemble parce que parfois on en
parlait des enseignants d'autres manuels
et personnalisées comme évidemment quand
on en arrivera là on travaillera sur
l'ensemble des ajustements les
enseignants ce sera à partir de la
mi-avril fin avril est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres publics prioritaires dans les
écoles que vous avez identifié
en clair si les professeurs sont
concernés ce qu'il ya aussi les atsem
il ya aussi toutes les personnes et la
cantine de l'administratif d'amande les
personnes des écoles sont concernées à
partir de rien moi de santé publique ce
n'est pas un combat de statut j'insiste
là dessus
notre enjeu vous voyez bien que c'est
tout le personnel des écoles nous ferons
les choses fonctionnent d'arrivée des
doses en fonction de ce qui nous est
recommandée si les autorités sanitaires
le monde bien que c'est au tour des
enfants qu'on a aujourd'hui à ce moment
là les plus grands risques de développer
notamment des cas évidemment moi je peux
vous dire en tant que mise la fonction
publique
il est évident que l'enjeu ce sont les
lieux de travail sont des pratiques
professionnelles
ce n'est pas la nature de votre contrat
ni le nom votre employé donc en clair
vraiment à part en clair si les
instituteurs dans une école dans une
classe sans vacciner tous les personnels
autour le seront aussi tous les
personnels qui sont en contact avec les
enfants de la même manière et à partir
de la mi avril de la même année je n'ai
pas aujourd'hui vous voyez la date parce
que on fait les choses par étapes
ça revient à ce que notre philosophie
sur l'a7 crise nous gérons les choses
avec beaucoup de transparence
d'abord on vaccine tous ceux qui sont
les plus à risque de développer une
forme grave je pense que les français
comprennent très bien que c'est beaucoup
plus efficace de s'assurer d'abord que
les gens soient moins exposé à les
formes graves et donc à de la
réanimation et donc lé risque de décès
et qu'ensuite nous vaccinerons ceux qui
sont les plus exposées avec un
calendrier qui sera défini un portable
moi ce qui est important c'est qu'on
frappart des risques et pas du statut
des gens parce que sinon on crée des
inégalités et des choses effet le lieu
de travail qu'on compte vous l'avez
l'administration a beaucoup été pointé
du doigt dans la gestion de cette crise
notamment les ars les agences régionales
de santé qui n'ont pas su coordonner les
opérations les tests etc
est ce que finalement ce n'est pas toute
l'administration qui n'a pas été à la
hauteur de cette situation moi je
voudrais vous dire évidemment il ya des
leçons à tirer et d'ailleurs on les tire
chaque jour
et quand il faut s'adapter on s'adapte
chaque jour mais je ne peux pas laisser
dire que notre pays n'aurait pas tenu
que les hommes et les femmes ne seraient
pas organisées aujourd'hui on est un des
pays qui testent le plus en europe ont
fait près de 2 millions à 3 millions de
tests par semaine
mais alors qu'est-ce que ce procès qui
est fait à l'administration vous le vous
reconnaissez qu'a livré ou pas ce que je
reconnais c'est que y'avait pas un plan
caché on n'est pas infaillible et nous
sommes tout à fait à chaque instant dans
la recherche de la plus grande
efficacité du plus grand équilibre à la
fin ce sont les politiques qui sont
responsables
c'est nous qui prenons les décisions
c'est nous qui devons corriger le tir
quand c'est nécessaire
et vous ne me verrez jamais
contrairement par exemple à certains ans
et arnaud montebourg qui explique à tous
les français que si l'administration
l'avait écouté il aurait réussi c'est ça
qui alimentent aussi la défiance des
français c'est vous qui avez le pouvoir
de l'administration ce qui se présente
en responsable du français sont est
politique et donc il ya des leçons à
tirer évidemment il y aura des leçons de
structures attirer les agences ravirait
restantes et elles sont menacées
non mais aujourd'hui avec le prêt me
souviens on a pris des décisions très
fortes mais des agences régionales de
santé sans aux fonctionnaires qui sont
aujourd'hui dans les ministères centraux
hauts fonctionnaires des fonctionnaires
qui sont aujourd'hui mises admis
centrales vont être redéployés en 2021
dans les préfectures dans les soap
réfection en proximité des élus dé
d'entreprise et citoyen est revenu en
verrons bien oui moi je suis pas là pour
mettre la tête de quiconque sur une
pique de vous dire la danse est clos
mais ce que les agences régionales de
santé elles ont encore un avenir
bien sûr qu'elles ont à venir pour parce
que s'occuper dans une région la santé
publique c'est évidemment une priorité
en suivant peut parler de la gouvernance
on en train de faire évoluer les choses
on peut parler tu es sont pas menacées
dans leur existence
aujourd'hui vous voyez c'est trop facile
de considérer comme un problème on met
la tête d'une structure où quelqu'un sur
une pique et on considère le premier
réglé nous règle les problèmes
alors justement al'inverse on a vu que
l'organisation de la vaccination
n'avaient pas été très efficace est ce
qu'il aurait pas fallu laisser ça à la
sécurité sociale tout simplement là
aussi regardons les choses en face notre
pays a autant vacciner aujourd'hui en
proportion de sa population que
l'allemagne que l'italie que l'espagne
où on en avait qui avait un démarrage
assez poussif on avait du mal à obtenir
des rumeurs à nous avec besikats l'alto
lire ça fendrait sécurité sociale elle
aurait fait ça mieux peut-être ça aurait
été plus vite tout le monde est mobilisé
sécurité sociale et mobilisez vous voyez
encore aujourd'hui le président la
montre à créteil les pompiers les locaux
tous les médecins et les infirmières en
formation l'ensemble du pays est
mobilisé autour de cet enjeu qui est un
enjeu crucial de sortie de crise mais là
aussi ne disons pas n'alimenteront pas
les peurs aujourd'hui près de 8 millions
de français ont reçu une première dose
c'est la même proportion dans tous les
pays européens pourquoi parce que nous
recevons et c'est une bonne nouvelle
les doses à proportion de notre
population si au début les choses ont
été plus longue à se mettre en place
nous avons ajusté le tir est aujourd'hui
la france n'est pas en retard
l'autre enjeu c'est qu'ils les doses
arrive que nous les produisions que nous
évitions et on est très content
la guerre des doses sur les tarmacs
comme on a pu voir d'autres moment sur
les bases des masques aujourd'hui nous
avons évité cela et c'est une réussite
qu'on va y revenir tout à l'heure mais
on vote pour par exemple les plus de 75
ans et la cnam qui va gérer ça on aurait
pu décider de le faire avant finalement
je peux vous dire j'étais dans beaucoup
de mairies les centres communaux
d'action sociale ont appelé ont
accompagné ce nombre de personnes dans
de très grands noms dans les ehpad
aujourd'hui vous à une couverture
vaccinale mais ferait peut être la
caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
dès le début et qui s'inscrit chargé
aujourd'hui on a des doses on peut donc
déployer parce qu'on est une semaine va
recevoir plus de 3 millions de doses de
vaccins une stratégie de massification
qui n'auraient pas eu grand sens à
déployer au moment où nous étions toutes
façons en flux tendu donc qui est des
étapes que les choses évoluent qu'on
s'ajuste c'est le bon sens via on va
parler maintenant je fais confiance mais
je tiens vraiment à le dire ce discours
qui consiste à dire rien n'a marché
et tout est la faute de l'administration
d'abord on s'est beaucoup ajusté je
pense que les français voient que nous
sommes un pays qui a tenu des mutations
a bien fait son travail et je tiens avec
la responsabilité elle est sur scène les
politiques nous devons avoir en
permanence la vigilance de nous dire ici
on corrige le tir on doit le faire bien
on va parler maintenant du plan de
relance parce que ça c'est aussi un
autre aspect qui compte je parlais tout
à l'heure en ouvrant les missions de
l'avenir et le plan de relance qui va
concilier oui notamment avec le fait que
vous avez donné le coup d'envoi au sous
préfet à la relance on se le rappelle
l'été dernier c'est sous préfets qui
sont présents dans les départements pour
coordonner les aides de l'état liées à
la crise qu'elle est aujourd'hui leur
bilan le milan c'est vous avez 24
milliards d'euros comme l'annoncé au
bord de la mer qui ont déjà étaient
déployés on a un cadre du plan de
relance qui a déjà été décaissés
comment ça s'est fait par un choix très
fort assumé qui veut dire quand vous
lancez pas des grands chiffres dans les
tableaux excel
c'est un contact de terrain avec les
patrons pme avec les locaux le plus
proche de là où sont les projets pour
que en face de l'argent et des projets
justement les aujourd'hui les élus 10
élus locaux les sénateurs critique
beaucoup c'est sous préfet à la relance
ils disent ils sont hors sol sont pas
les facilitateurs qu'on nous avait vendu
au départ qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez à bord je leur réponds que
j'ai lu les débats il y avait aussi
d'autres sénateurs qui ont pensé des
choses beaucoup plus positive mais il y
en a eu beaucoup
leur crime que j'en ai aussi sur le
terrain je dois vous dire j'étais encore
un département où voyez en bourgogne
quand la semaine dernière à dijon et
bien les pme
les patrons de pme les élus locaux ils
ont alors disposition quelqu'un qui
effectivement n'a pas toutes les clefs
vous imaginez bien parce qu'il faut
quand même que une forme d'organisation
directement mais qui est d'abord alors
contact qui fait émerger des projets qui
simplifie les choses je vous répondais
aux sénateurs qui disent ce sont des
gens qui sont hors sol qui arrive comme
ça qui vient les surveiller qu'il ya une
méfiance vis-à-vis des collectes comment
un état qui n'a aucune méfiance avec des
collectivités on est là pour appuyer et
accompagner les projets mais si vous
parlez uniquement aux maires des grandes
métropoles ça ils ont le numéro de
téléphone de bruno le maire au numéro
téléphone et jacqueline gourault on peut
faire des grands contrats saas signés
chez le premier ministre
pour ces élus là évidemment que les
sous-préfets la relance ils doivent être
vus comme des choses qui ne sont pas
nécessaires dans la vie quotidienne
quand vous êtes l'élu d'une petite
commune que vous avez un projet par
exemple j'ai vu de développement d'une
centrale hydrogène d'une petite
intercommunalité rural vous voulez faire
un projet de biomasse vous avez ni le
téléphone de l'homme jacking ronnie
téléphone de bruno le maire est le vôtre
il faut obtenir ni personne vous êtes
quand même très content que dans vos
départements vous ayez une personne
identifiée qui puisse avec vous monter
le projet le solidifiait et le faire
financer les chinois m'ont ans je vis
c'est pas de rentrer dans les débats
parisien savoir si l'état doit être
repensée refonder ici les commissions
comme ça c'est comment sur le terrain
les élus les chefs d'entreprise
notamment des patrons de pme notamment
les élus des plus petites communes ont
un état en face de qui est un
interlocuteur de confiance qui a un
numéro de téléphone qui est un visage
qui peut se rendre dans les communes et
qui fait ce travail de proximité que
l'état pendant des années a délaissé et
quitterait la défiance brigitte moi je
dis aux sénateurs ils je suis ravi que
ceux et celles qui ont eu ces propos
viennent avec moi j'ai pas l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui ce passe comme une donnée
à l'herbier vous et sur les 100
milliards et à 26 milliards d'euros qui
ont été décaissés pour l'instant sur le
plan de relance est ce que ça peut pas
aller plus vite et on a lancé ce plan au
mois de septembre
il est dans les chiffres du budget
depuis le 1er janvier
on est aujourd'hui à la fin du mois de
mars on a décaissé un quart d'un plan
qui a une durée de 2
d'abord on n'est pas en retard
deuxièmement les projets deviennent
concret troisièmement les chefs
d'entreprise retrouve des perspectives
d'investissement d'innovation de
croissance ce sont des dizaines des
centaines de milliers d'emplois qui sont
sécurisées qu'on peut pas aller plus
vite
pourquoi ne pas mettre en service parce
que soit vous avez une économie
dirigiste l état décide pour tout le
monde ce qui doit faire soit vous faites
confiance aux acteurs de terrain
vous leur montrez les priorités les
projets émergent et c'est normal que
tout le monde n'est pas à vous y ait
anticipé ce qui l'avait vouloir faire
avec notamment un soutien public et ce
matin bruno le maire a dit qu'on
pourrait décaissé plus que 100 milliards
éventuellement on est toujours là dans
le quoi qu'il en coûte on en est pas
sorti bon on a toujours dit que tant que
les restrictions sanitaires pesait sur
la vie quotidienne des entreprises
le quoi qu'il en coûte serait là on a
toujours dit ça ensuite évidemment quand
la crise ne sera plus la crise que
connaît aujourd'hui on va pas continuer
infiniment à faire des mécanismes de
crise il est plus la crise la relance
elle a été calibré par rapport à un
besoin économique était celui du moment
où il a été présenté mon ange déjà c'est
que les 100 milliards il actionne le
terrain ils soient accessibles aux
entreprises qui ont des projets quelle
que soit leur taille
accessible aux élus locaux quelle que
soit leur territoire c'est déjà un
énorme travail et voyez là aussi faisons
déjà
ce qui est bien ce qui est prévu
évidemment la crise nous apprend à être
souple et nous adapter mais je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui mon ans je sais nous
assure qu'il n'y ait pas de territoires
oubliés
ça c'est le rôle de l'état vous l'avez
dit dernière question de table puis dire
la question de brigitte mais on a
beaucoup parlé de la fonction publique
on va parler de la haute fonction
publique ou est-ce que vous en êtes de
la réforme de l'ena si elle devait être
présenté en juin est ce que c'est
toujours le cas et en quoi cette réforme
va-t-elle consisté est-ce que ça va pas
juste être cosmétiques juste le
changement de nom puis on va repartir
comme avant car d'abord c'est pas à la
réforme une école c'est la fin de toute
la gouvernance delà des politiques
publiques et donc de l'encadrement
supérieur de l'état
ces trois shows cette réforme avec aucun
renoncement je peux vous dire sur
l'ambition que nous avons entre le
président république est prémuni c'est
pour le mois de juin mais c'est au plus
tard toute façon promulguée avant le 7
juin
donc les choses sont clairement partie
pour être tenu moi je suis une femme
une ministre qui tient ses engagements
donc c'est un engagement qui sera tenu
il ya trois choses dans la réforme qui
est la nouvelle génération de hauts
fonctionnaires qu'on veut faire émerger
comment on recrute des jeunes de tous
les territoires
des filières de formation à l'université
comment on casse l'autocensure de
beaucoup de jeunes qui ont beaucoup de
talent et qui ont l'aspiration que cette
haute fonction publique soit aussi un
ascenseur social c'est ce que nous avons
annoncé avec ces classes prépas talent
ils seront dans toutes les régions de
france pour permettre à chacun de
pouvoir préparer les concours sans avoir
à venir à paris
deuxième élément c'est une formation un
tronc commun du cac ce corporatisme et
qu'ils fassent qu'entre un magistrat un
préfet un commissaire de police un
directeur d'hôpital
la formation met beaucoup plus de sujets
en commun pour qu'on puisse mieux se
comprendre mais travaillent ensemble et
enfin c'est une nouvelle gestion des
carrières des hauts fonctionnaires est
beaucoup plus d'évaluation on a commencé
avec les préfets avaient vu qu'on a
interministériel 10 et leur feuille de
route leur évaluation leur rémunération
au mérite parce qu'on a besoin d'avoir
un système qui pour qu'on ait les bonnes
personnes au bon endroit donne aussi
beaucoup plus grande place aux résultats
des actions qui sont menées et moins de
place a parfois des formes de
corporatisme mountain men de tous petite
parenthèse on parle beaucoup vous savez
d'affaires de harcèlement sexuel dans
les grandes écoles à l'ena il ya rien eu
alors aujourd'hui dans tous les
ministères dans toutes les écoles de
service public on a les siens le
signalement est allé diana pas je n'ai
pas connaissance à ce stade de
signalement mais je peux vous dire que
dans tous les ministères par la loi nous
avons maintenant des cellules de
signiant qui sont hors hiérarchie pour
nous assurer que quiconque peut signaler
des faits répréhensibles de harcèlement
devient sexuelle de discrimination
d'atteinte à la laïcité bref tout ce qui
ne permet pas travailler dans un cadre
serein qui respectent pleinement le
statut l'égalité la neutralité la
probité et que ça se fait en dehors de
la hiérarchie parce que sinon on voit
bien que les pas de signalement aller là
pour l'instant je n'ai pas connaissance
des questions d'audrey pulvar qui est
candidate socialiste aux régionales en
ile-de-france elle a dit que les blancs
pouvaient assister à des réunions de
personnes discriminées en raison de leur
couleur de peau mais à condition qu'il
se taise
est ce que vous êtes du côté de ce que
cela choque évidemment l'idée même qu'on
puisse séparer le comportement des uns
ou des autres soient couleur de peau est
contraire à une république est
indivisible qui est unie et qui ne
laisse place à aucune forme de racisme
donc dans mon pays tel que je le conçois
nous sommes des hommes et des femmes qui
pour vous
exprimé sur beaucoup de sujets mais la
couleur de peau n'a rien à faire avec
ces enjeux et pourtant christophe
castaner quel président du groupe la
raim à l'assemblée nationale estime que
ce genre de réunion sont nécessaires
c'est une division ça dans l'âme acronis
avoue divisent je pense pas que ça nous
divisent je pense qu'on est extrêmement
clair sur d'ailleurs les principes
républicains
je le fait que le racisme qu'il soit
d'un côté ou de l'autre d'une certaine
façon on n'a aucune place et que nous
soyons extrêmement fermes sur ce qui
fait l'unité notre pays l'unité notre
région nous sommes je crois sur ces
sujets extrêmement unanime
merci brigitte des mercis table le débat
sur la loi climat il vient de commencer
à l'assemblée nationale il était
retransmis tout à l'heure avant
comprennent nantes n1 cieux sur lcp
barbara pompili mise de la transition
écologique y voient une nouvelle façon
de faire la loi
parce qu'après la convention citoyenne
ya le débat à l'assemblée et après il y
aura un référendum
on va l'entendre après le temps des
citoyens voici le temps des élus de la
nation et ce tandis parlement j'y suis
extrêmement attachée
parce que c'est celui de la démocratie
représentative des débats au grand jour
et des votes qui gravent désespoir dans
le marbre de la loi
c'est ainsi ensemble que nous allons
répondre à l'appel de la convention
citoyenne
cet ensemble que nous allons passer de
150 françaises et français à 577
aujourd'hui est à 67 millions demain à
lille dimanche à l'ats la loi climat ça
fait partie de la transformation public
ça c'est la dernière le dernier grand
texte du quinquennat je pense pas que ce
soit le dernier grand texte
c'est une innovation démocratique sera
quoi le derrière je sais pas vous dire
quel est l'agenda parlementaire jeudi on
est en train de faire des passes dernier
grand texte du cac et non la loi 4d qui
arrive est un texte important
d'organisations l'état donc rejoint pas
faire dérailler les premiers ou les
derniers ce qui compte dans cette loi
c'est d'abord l'innovation démocratique
être capable sur un sujet complexe
d'associer les citoyens de faire venir
des gens qui au départ ne sont pas des
experts et de réfléchir des enjeux de la
vie quotidienne que ça pourrait se faire
ailleurs
mais bien sûr c'est plus rare exemple
vous êtes vous aurez une idée comme ça
vole pourquoi je vous dis ça comme ça
c'est des enjeux mais alors sous des
formats qui peuvent varier mais je pense
par exemple vous savez par exemple les
enjeux de bioéthique typiquement des
sujets où on a toujours d'ailleurs
travaillé avec des consultations très
large
l'idée que ce n'est pas seulement les
sachant qu'ils ont un mot à dire que ça
concerne toute la société et peux vous
dire aujourd'hui que vous savez dans les
enquêtes qu'on fait sur la confiance des
français des occidentaux dans la
démocratie créé une démocratie
délibérative pas juste de la démocratie
participative on fait des votations tous
les matins mais de la démocratie
délibérative informer accompagner ce
sont des choses qui à mon avis sont au
coeur du 21e siècle
bien des choses qu'il nous faudra
approfondir il très rare nous a rejoint
bonsoir yves brossard directeur du
figaro et de montchalin alors le conseil
scientifique vient de me remettre son
rapport sur les élections régionales qui
doivent qui devait on ne sait pas
comment on peut dire mais en principe
avoir lieu à deuxième quinzaine du mois
de juin et ce conseil scientifique dit
ouah ça serait évidemment mieux qu'ils
n'aient pas lieu pour pas accélérer la
contamination mais c'est aux pouvoirs
politiques de décider ça vous convient
comme décision
alors mon rapport je n'ai pas lu le
rapport parce que comme vous dites il à
quelques heures et donc il est important
que chacun puisse le lire en détail
ma conviction ce sujet c'est d'abord ça
te demande quelle que soit la décision
que y ait une forme de partage avec les
autres formations politiques doit être
une décision partagée
d'autant plus partagés qu'on a déjà eu
une expérience moment des municipales
oui qui a quand même mené à beaucoup des
responsabilités entre ce qui était
partisan qu'on les tienne absolument et
qui ensuite ont été très très vite
partisan qu'on les annuler absolument
donc ce n'est pas le gouvernement qui
décidera tout seul mais bon on décidera
ou bien évidemment pas tout seul le
président de la république doit recevoir
les autres formations politiques
je sais pas moi de faire les formats
d'invitation dirigeons maintenant
d'abord ça doit être une décision
partagée ouais et ça doit être une
décision assumée
vous savez le cun doit prendre ses
responsabilités on a vécu l'année
dernière au mois de mars
des scènes qui était objectivement et
politiquement et démocratiquement
quand je te prie psychodrame qui n'était
pas à l'honneur d'une démocratie comme
la nôtre
vous êtes d'accord pour dire que tous
les pays des grands pays démocratiques
ce dès a pas empêchés de voter les
pays-bas récemment les états unis
d'espagne le real dans certaines
certains länder
donc on devrait pouvoir voter pourquoi
la vie démocratique s'arrêterait d'abord
c'est une décision qui doit être
partagée
parce que gagner opposition et une
majorité il faut que les choses se
passent de manière consensuelle entre
tous les participants un scrutin ouais
ça la démocratie c'est qu'on se
reconnaissent dans le processus qu'on
lance la même chose s'y invente deux
pays qui sur des élections régionales ou
locales ne les ont pas tenus que les
élections nationales en général sont
venus mais parfois avec des précautions
notamment d'organisation mais il n'ya
pas que la date il ya qu'est ce que ça
veut dire de faire campagne
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de faire
campagne à distance en numérique qu'est
ce qui est autorisé et ce qu'on change
les règles de certaines positions de
certaines capacités par exemple à
travailler sur les réseaux sociaux pour
faire sa campagne
y'a pas que la date et les conditions se
tiennent ces cas le jeu démocratique et
dans ce jeu démocratique
est ce que vous vous allez vous engager
dans ces élections alors que vous êtes
une élue à l'origine de l'île de france
est ce que vous allez faire campagne
avec monsieur saint martin pour cette
campagne est déjà dit je serai candidate
en essonne très engagé est-ce que je
pense que ces élections seront un moment
de vérité
ouais pour que nous puissions faire des
propositions ramener le débat politique
aussi des choses concrètes ce que les
français attendent et aussi pour ramener
dans le débat le fait que le projet de
certains ouais dans certaines régions
dans ce stade départemental ou régional
qui est de dire mon projet c'est de
lutter contre l'état n'est pas en soi un
projet alors restons ont besoin de
projets clairs et donc dans l'île de
france dans ce territoire qui m'a élu
député en 2017 je peux vous dire que
nous avons beaucoup d'enjeux oui que la
région peut beaucoup faire alors raison
nous restons là précisément en ile de
france il ya un schéma qui est assez
simple avec une présidente sortante qui
fait course en tête dans les études
d'opinion révéré pécresse j'avais
notamment valérie pécresse vous avez un
candidat rassemblement national qui est
assez qu'il hacker derrière et puis la
république en marche
et puis les formations de gauche au
deuxième tour est-ce que vous jouez le
front républicain pour faire barrage au
rassemblement national ou est-ce que
vous fait cause commune avec les
républicains madame pécresse
d'abord nous avons une ligne toujours
clair nous ne ferons jamais marche pied
à un parti de marine le pen qui me
séparent les propositions qui alimente
le mensonge pour ça c'est la première
réponse est dans les faits que news
l'animation des peurs et qui propose aux
français n'ont pas les solutions à des
manceaux
d'accord c'était un premier acte nous ne
serons jamais les marchepieds pour
l'accès au pouvoir du front national du
roi semble à son tour s'il était en
mesure de pouvoir gagner la région
vous pourriez faire cause commune avec
valérie pécresse avec toute personne qui
a pour action de lutter contre
l'accession au pouvoir d'un parti qui
n'a pas de solution à proposer que des
mensonges
vous êtes en train de dire ce que le
front républicain encore une
signification bien au combat toute la
journée ce qui alimente les peurs et
propose des noms solution français dont
je peux pas vous dire ici que pour des
raisons voyez électoraliste notre notre
ligne aurait dévié est ce que cette
élection ces élections régionales sont
pour vous une forme de test avant
l'élection présidentielle qui aura lieu
dans 13 mois maintenant
c'est un moment nous devons parler des
enjeux de chaque région les compétences
de la région la région s occupe de
l'information de l'orientation des
jeunes est ce que les transports elle
s'occupe du développement économique
mais vous êtes tous ces sujets mais peu
ancré dans le territoire
on a toujours la possibilité s'ancrer en
ayant un projet et nous notre vision de
la politique depuis 2010 est certes on
nous avait dit au départ on était naïf
parce qu'on voulait proposer des autour
d'idées amateurs mais sa seule présence
de rappeler projet camps depuis des
années on avait servi aux français d
parfois des accords d'appareil très
compliqué de partis qui étaient plus des
uniques unis donc ce que c'est un test
évidemment un moment où la majorité
présidentielle va d'abord pouvoir
montrer comment elle conçoit son
international comment elle conçoit son
action régionale
comment les deux peuvent être plus
cohérente d'accord comment qu'est ce
qu'on va faire cela relance qu'est ce
qu'on va faire vis-à-vis de la jeunesse
évidemment quand on est à un an d'une
élection
les élections intermédiaires ont un sens
mais vous êtes le plus grand test pour
2022 oui c'est quels sont les résultats
que nous aurons à montrer aux français
est-ce que ça va se jouer en 2022
justement sur cette crise sanitaire et
la façon dont le pouvoir exécutif a géré
cette crise ça se jouera sur notre
manière d'avoir pris nos responsabilités
on a parlé avant ça se jouera aussi sur
notre bilan
oui on dit toujours habile on ne fait
pas réélire alors il faut si vous n'avez
pas de guidances n'est pas candidat et
certains ont payé pour voir au cours des
dernières années donc d'abord il faut
c'est mon rôle avec ce baromètre des
résultats tous les atouts les
téléspectateurs peuvent aller sur le
site du gouvernement
pour voir les résultats pour voir dans
leur département politique prioritaire
par politiques prioritaires sur 25
politiques publiques qui deviendront 36
au début du mois de mai l'ensemble des
résultats m'ont ans je sais que les
français puissent juger par eux-mêmes
non pas sur des anathèmes des concepts
évidemment qu'il y aura des nouvelles
propositions à faire vous êtes d'accord
avec moi pour dire qu'il ya eu plusieurs
étapes dans cette crise sanitaire que
certaines étapes aurait peut-être mérité
de la part du président de la république
quelques excuses ou dû dire que je me
suis trompé comme madame merkel l'a fait
récemment en allemagne
vous croyez pas qu'il aurait pu faire un
mea culpa quand même sur certaines
choses tous les jours tous les jours
notre gouvernement n'est pas à se
demander si on doit santé était pour
défendre l'indéfendable
quand il ya une attestation qui partent
pas bien il ya plus d'attestation on la
change on s'adapte quand sur des
décisions de vaccination au départ on se
rend compte que notre organisation ne
permet pas d'état ses relances on la
change on s'adapte quand le présent la
république cherche à trouver le bon
équilibre sur la manière par exemple de
en ce moment parce qu'on a plus de doses
de vaccins d'aller plus loin on ça là on
s'adapte en permanence
madame merkel a fait même chose el hamel
fait excuser c'était elle a fait ça
aujourd'hui quand vous avez un président
qui vient dire j'assume
moi j'assume c'est plus fort que
s'excuser s'émeut pas dire j'ai raison
sur tout ça veut dire vous pouvez me
tenir et nous tenir responsables de
subventionne et de la manière dont nous
sommes allés constater que c'est bien il
ya une femme qui est candidate à cette
présidence de la république qui trouvent
que celui qui incarnerait le mieux son
opposition à l dans le cadre de ce
scrutin présidentiel c'est précisément
emmanuel macron est-ce que c'est marine
le pen qui disent à marine le pen qui
dit ça évidemment
est-ce que emmanuel macron ne serait pas
d'une certaine façon le meilleur
candidat de la droite pour cette
élection présidentielle d'abord je
voudrais pour faire ces questions je
vous le dis très solennellement way
madame le pen fait ce qu'elle a à faire
nous on a une fois d'affaires la
combattre oui maintenant mais sa belle
série montrent les mensonges
non elle dit mais l'électron est le
meilleur candidat de son camp c'est un
bel hommage non c'est plutôt assez
regard bleu comme ses opinions moi je
suis pas là pour commenter les hôpitaux
madeleine je suis la poire c'est un bel
hommage certains aux français toute la
journée ce sont des mensonges sont les
faits qui use et sonder des voies sans
issue mais qui valent à mâcon 65 ans
mais pas avec moi je ne commenterai pas
ce que pense maria est ce que alors
d'abord vous dire qu'on écoute toujours
en 2021 que tous les scénarios
en général un an avant l'élection
présidentielle sont rarement couronnée
de succès et que par ailleurs en 2021 il
me semble qu'avant de parler 2022 on a
beaucoup occupé beaucoup pas fait on est
confiant il se pourrait que il n'y ait
pas un match retour de 2017 en 2022
entre madame le pen et monsieur macron
c'est pas à moi de le dire mais moi je
suis membre d'un gouvernement qui prend
c'est l'enjeu ils cherchent à avoir un
bilan
l'enjeu aujourd'hui est ce que il se
joue entre un candidat ou une candidate
qui pourrait incarner espèce de de
localisme puisque c'est madame le pen
qui emploie ce mot là c'est à dire une
fibre nationale on va dire ou
nationalistes et puis en face quelqu'un
qui a un tempérament et qui est beaucoup
plus ouvert sur le monde comme on peut
le prétendre monsieur macron c'est un
peu schématique et c5 avons défendu
depuis trois ans la souveraineté
européenne qui dans cette crise se voit
tous les jours nos stratégies de dire on
va éviter la guerre des doses des
vaccins sur les tarmacs d'un rapport
qu'on a pu voir sur les masques et ça a
retardé aussi beaucoup la stratégie
consiste aujourd'hui à ce que dans un
espace qui est l'espace européen nous
n'ayons pas des pays qu'ils soient dans
des situations sanitaires très très
grave
alors que d'autres pourraient parce
qu'il sait ils ont ils sont les aux plus
offrants être protégé c'est un choix de
civilisation
on n'est pas des européens on n'est pas
des mots d'hier qui essayent 22 sera un
choix de civilisation
je pense que 2022 se jouera d'abord sur
la capacité dans une démocratie a montré
qu'on peut être efficace et que donc les
engagements pris en 2007 ont été tenus
je pense que le bilan c'est un moment
essentiel 2022 se gérera sur la capacité
aussi à donner des perspectives dans un
monde qu'il faudra reconstruire et je
pense que l'enjeu européen effectivement
sera un enjeu majeur qu'est ce qu'on a à
dire sur le numérique
qu'est ce qu'on a à dire sur le
mécanisme carbone aux frontières qu'est
ce qu'on a à dire sur des enjeux
migratoires
tous ces enjeux là ce sont des anges
aujourd'hui européen si vous pensez que
vous pour les résoudre tout seul france
est isolée et on voit bien d'ailleurs
que le breakbeat
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de commentaires
qui sont faits aujourd'hui
économiquement diplomatiquement
commercialement sur beaucoup d'enjeux
qui vont finir par concernés très
rapidement la vie quotidienne des
britanniques que sanitairement ça va
plus vite chez eux que chez nous tient à
voir et à savoir quand est-ce que la
deuxième chose pour être donnée aux
britanniques déjà parce que chacun fait
ses choix qui ont leurs avantages et
leurs inconvénients
il n'y a pas que des avantages à ce qui
était joyeux hui loin de là merci merci
et sa base il vend directement à la
séquence d'après bravo merci d'avoir
terminé là dessus parce que la façon
dans l'union européenne gère des stocks
de vaccins
c'est un échec pour beaucoup je rappelle
que vous avez été misés des affaires
européennes au début du quinquennat
avant d'être à ce poste à cause
notamment d'astrazeneca qui ne livre pas
les doses prévues dont l'efficacité du
vaccin est remise en cause hier clément
boon qui est maintenant secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes a révélé
que la france allait récupérer deux
millions de do sur un stock de 29
millions retrouver dans une usine de
production en italie
est ce que c'est normal lorsqu est pas
normal c'est que quand des grandes
entreprises s'engagent sur un enjeu
aussi stratégique que la vaccination les
engagements ne sont pas tenus
ensuite ce qui est normal c'est que nous
partagions les doses entre européens
qu'on en retrouve comme ça dans des
usines on sait pas d'où ça vient là pour
trouver 10 millions de doses ce que ça
veut dire c'est que nous avons avec
cette entreprise pharmaceutique un
énorme problème de tenue des engagements
et donc c'est sur ce terrain là de la
tenue des engagements du suivi très
méthodique que nous avons à travailler
si vous saviez que sur les exportations
nous contrôlons très fortement après je
tiens à vous dire que là dans les tout
prochains jours nous allons en france
produits embouteillés des vaccins notre
capacité de production en train d'être
décuplée par les autres européens
on aura de plus en plus de capacité à
produire chez nous et en cause il est
aussi à fournir les pays les moins
développés en vaccins c'est un ange est
aussi très important et beaucoup de gens
qui vous donnent des leçons et qui
oublient que si nous ne vaccinerons pas
les soignants afrique
sinon nous n'ont pas accès aux vaccins
aux populations les plus pauvres de la
planète c'est aussi la lutte contre
l'épidémie qui a moins la bière ne sera
pas possible on va cueillir maintenant
les deux parlementaires qui nous ont
rejoints pour débattre avec vous
[Musique]
bonsoir loïc hervé bonsoir mathilde de
panneaux un santé l'un après l'autre
loïc hervé vous êtes sénateur udi de
haute savoie et vous êtes par ailleurs
présent délégué de l'association des
petites villes de france je dis ça parce
qu'un mini manche alain est allé faire
une visite l'autre jour dans une
associée dans une mairie qui fait partie
de cette association et bonsoir mathilde
de panneaux vous êtes député
la france a soumises du val de marne et
vice président du groupe et les filles à
l'assemblée nationale on va commencer
par ordre alphabétique comme je le fais
à chaque fois et donc loïc hervé vous
sortez à l'instant de créer une
commission mixte paritaire sur la
sécurité loi sur la loi sécurité globale
plus exactement
et c'est là dessus que vous vouliez
débattre d'abord avec amélie montchanin
d'abord pour vous donner madame la
ministre une bonne nouvelle c'est un
père était conclusive entre les députés
et les sénateurs
nous avons trouvé un accord sur ce texte
au terme d'un débat parlementaire long
qui a commencé ici l'assemblée nationale
avec un des puits avec un débat un
rapport avant le débat rapport des
collègues fauvergue et tour au qui ont
écrit un rapport qui a créé une
proposition de loi et qui ce texte est
venu en débat à l'assemblée nationale
et vous savez l'article 24 a causé de
grandes difficultés dans la presse dans
dans les médias au centre si tu as et
sur la possibilité de diffuser ou pas
des images de forces de l'ordre quand
elles sont en actes et en actions
absolument et donc c'est le bicamérisme
à la française qui a permis de résoudre
le problème
et finalement c'est parce que nous avons
eu cette navette parlementaire une
lecture à l'assemblée et une lecture au
sénat que nous deux chambres ont servi
de caisse de résonance de caisse aussi
d'amortissement pour permet de trouver
une solution
ma question c'est le train de mon
interpellation c'est à dire que en même
temps qu'on a cette loi qui est une
proposition de loi qui est d'essence
parlementaire on a eu l'inscription d'un
texte qui est un projet de loi qu'elle
texte séparatisme avec un article 24
dans la proposition de loi sécurité
globale et un article 18
dans le texte séparatisme qui sont des
articles proches et le problème qu'on a
et convie au parlement et que nouveaux
téléspectateurs doivent doivent savoir
c'est que il ya près de chronologie et
que l'articulation entre les deux textes
une vraie difficulté et moi ma question
c'est comment dans cette cinquième
république on peut laisser plus de place
au travail des parlementaires à
l'initiative parlementaire
et que le gouvernement accepte d'avoir
une chronologie qui permettent d'éviter
que la biotech se percutaient suis pas
l'ami de l'intérieur donc je vais pas
vous présenter en détail les enjeux de
chronologie des plans et le
fonctionnement de l'assemblée
j'ai été député donc je vois très bien
l'enjeu de donner à notre parlement en
france plus de moyens notamment
d'évaluation déjà des lois pour qu'ils
puissent quand il prend des initiatives
parlementaires avoir plus de moyens pour
calibrer aussi son travail quand je fais
ce travail sur le baromètre des
résultats l'action publique c'est aussi
un moyen de donner aux parlementaires
beaucoup plus de données sur l'état réel
du pays sur ceux qui progressent au ceux
qui progressent moins sur ce qui
pourrait peut-être dans leur territoire
mais qui ne progresse pas ailleurs moi
je suis très attaché ce qui est
effectivement de notre démocratie
le parlement puisse avoir plus de moyens
travaillent notamment sur son suivi de
la mise en oeuvre des lois
les deux texans vous parlez sont des
textes extrêmement important sur le
continuum de sécurité sur la police
municipale sur évidemment la défense des
principes républicains
mais nous savons dans ces matières il ya
évidemment la force du texte et il ya
ensuite la bonne mise en oeuvre
commandant la réalité dans six mois dans
neuf mois dans un an on sera capable de
se demander si les mécanismes sont
opérant s'il fonctionne dans ce cadre là
moi je suis très attaché à ce que
notamment ce travail d'évaluation soient
mieux armés c'était un de mes combats
quand j'étais député et que j'ai
d'ailleurs je poursuis du sénat manière
on vous donne ans avoue parlementaire
beaucoup plus d'éléments
ça vous suffisent y est aussi jugé pas
vous c'est fini ça nous suffit les
bonnes volontés manami sauce aux sons de
bonnes à prendre ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que le sénat et ce soir la cmp
ont mis dans le texte tout un tas de
garantie qui permette d'exercer ce
contrôle c'est pas le gouvernement qui 2
sa volonté donnent des idées des comptes
rendus au parlement
c'est selon la constitution le
gouvernement qui doit le faire et dans
la loi telle que nous l'avons prévu dans
le texte il est il est nécessaire
d'avoir ces garanties qu'ils ont
apportés et le sénat et la cmp up sur
miss paritaire maison mais il paraît
tard par la suite a aussi conforté c'est
un moyen d'avancer alors tout à l'heure
tous les deux vous parlerai de la
fonction publique qu'est ce qu'ils
aiment et dimanche à l'ats pour ça mais
vous avez aussi vous une question
précise mathilde panneaux autour de
l'eau et on part dans la fonction
publique tous les deux ans en oui alors
sur la question de l'eau parce que
vous le savez madame la ministre l'eau
est aujourd'hui en grand danger de par
le changement climatique
évidemment mais aussi de par
l'accaparement par des multinationales
qui sous investissent à beaucoup
d'endroits tel point que dans les fuites
on perd l'équivalent de la consommation
annuelle de 18,5 millions d'habitants ce
qui est absolument dramatique qu'on a
des grandes multinationales comme nestlé
ou danone qui vont pomper directement
dans la nappe phréatique pour envoyer
des eaux en bouteille en plastique à 70%
à l'export pendant que les habitants du
coin n'ont pas d'eau au robinet lorsque
le sait des cas de sécheresse et avec
des moyens qui manquent considérablement
le niveau de l'état qui assure
l'impunité des multinationales puisque
il ya très peu de contrôles c'est les
minéraliers qui disent eux-mêmes ce
qu'ils prennent dans la nappe et qu' il
ya aujourd'hui un agent de l'eau esb et
donc de l'office de la biodiversité pour
dix mille kilomètres de rivières ce qui
n'assure absolument pas de contrôle de
l'état donc nous avons lancé une
campagne avec des syndicales des
associations et des partis politiques
pour demander à ce que l'eau soit
inscrit dans la constitution
seriez vous prête à voter à cette
votation et reconnaissez vous que l'eau
est un bien commun et donc qu'elle
devrait être sorti des mains du marché
première chose c'est qu'effectivement
l'eau est un enjeu majeur pour
l'agriculture pour l'alimentation pour
notre environnement et donc je pense que
c'est un sujet d'ailleurs dont il faut
que beaucoup de français se saisissent
on a au point b tout le monde peut voter
sur la gouvernance de l'eau sur
notamment le rôle de la qualité de l'eau
j'ai à vous dire que je vous donne un
exemple nous accompagnent dans mon
ministère la transformation numérique de
l'état notamment des outils de plus
grand des deux contrôles notamment sur
la qualité de l'eau pour que les agents
que vous citez puisse beaucoup plus
efficacement repérer les lieux où l'eau
serait par exemple polluer ou nom propre
à la consommation et que nous les
aidions avec notamment de l'intelligence
artificielle et des algorithmes avec
beaucoup de politiques de la donner gros
travail d'investissement pour que
notamment nous assurions la qualité de
l'eau c'est évidemment un enjeu majeur
je crois que vous avez des travaux
parlementaires d'ailleurs qui vont être
lancés de manière transparente izan sur
le sujet et je pense que c'était un bon
sujet de débat d'ailleurs je me zaim
couture amis de l'environnement au sein
du gouvernement porte notamment avec
bien sûr les élus locaux à son de
projets dans le cas du plan de relance
d'ailleurs je note que c'est
l'investissement sur la remise en
condition à ce manque de canalisations
parce qu'il ya effectivement beaucoup de
fuites est un enjeu que nous portons au
coeur de ce plan de relance
donc c'est un enjeu on avis national
stratégique évidemment l'enjeu du
changement climatique approfondit encore
sa nécessité d'être débattue en tout cas
je sais pas si j'ai pas encore vu votre
compétition donc j'ai pas réparé à lire
aujourd'hui une votation citoyenne je
regarderai années passent et je serai le
document lewand a misé tout à l'heure
alors on va parler maintenant des
fonctionnaires parce que c'est le centre
de votre portefeuille le coeur de votre
portefeuille
et là vous avez deux parlementaires qui
n'ont pas le même avis sur la question
parce que vous avez loïc hervé qui dit
mais le président la république avait
pris des engagements et bâti de panneaux
qui dit oui mais peut-être les
engagements n'étaient pas forcément
c'est au rayonnement là qu'il faut
prendre
vous allez poser votre question loïc
hervé mais il enchaîna vous répondez
puis matip tanoh rebondir là dessus et
vous pourrez y débattre à madame le
ministre avant vous n'ayez été nommé là
dans le poste qui est le vôtre
actuellement j'avais eu l'occasion
d'être rapporteur au sénat du texte sur
la transformation de la fonction
publique alors c'est sûr c'était avant
la crise que nous vivons actuellement et
tout est remis en cause par cette crise
là cela s'entend seulement les ambitions
de transformation lavaud en public sont
réels ils doivent perdurer
nous avons besoin d'une fonction
publique à gilles nous avons le besoin
de renforcer les ponts entre le public
et le privé nous avons besoin d'avoir
des fonctionnaires plus nombreux dans
certains domaines mais beaucoup moins
nombreux dans d'autres par exemple
n'avons buzz mais moi je fais partie de
ceux qui pensent que l'état doit se
résumer à eau régalien et aux missions
essentielles et costis gendarmerie paul
innocemment peut-être dans notre pays et
dans notre histoire l'éducation en
grande partie en grande partie mais en
tout cas il ya des secteurs qui doivent
être et qui sont mieux ça rejoint
convient de se dire qu'ils sont mieux
administrée par le privé ou qui sont
mieux administrer qui montrent qu'ils
sont mieux administrées par des
personnes sous statut privé et ça je le
dis en tant qu'ancien maire on voit bien
dans une collectivité comme une mairie
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir toutes les
personnes qui travaillent dans la mairie
qui soit sous statut de fonctionnaire et
c'est d'ailleurs la loi sur la
transformation la fonction publique
portait à l'époque par olivier dussopt
up avait un objectif d'aller de la
d'aller vers ceux là il y avait des
objectifs chiffrés de réduction du
nombre de fonctionnaires en france où en
êtes-vous sur les 120 me la suppression
de postes un oui mais c'était dans la
suite vous avez
du débat sur la peau de la prévention où
en êtes vous de cette politique qui fait
qu'on nous doive avoir en france le
nombre de fonctionnaires qui correspond
à une administration qui soit efficace
dimanche à l'ats je viens de passer le
tout début de l'émission et je vous en
remercie de parler ce sujet sur le fait
que nous devions nous adapter lorsqu'il
serait aujourd'hui circonstances que
nous connaissons absolument pas adapté
d'expliquer que notre priorité serait de
réduire de manière comptable le nombre
de fonctionnaires mon combat est celui
du premier ministre était dire deux
choses stabiliser l'effectif sans ce
général et au sein de cette civilisation
real ou nos moyens là où nous avons des
besoins
on recrute des nouveaux professeurs ont
recreusé nouveaux policiers ont surtout
remet les bonnes personnes aux bons
endroits notamment beaucoup plus sur les
territoires nous avons pris la décision
dans ce schéma là d'avoir 2500 personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui dans les
administrations centrales redéployés
dans les préfectures et les sous
préfectures sur le territoire pour créer
de la proximité progrès l'efficacité
pour prendre des décisions
un niveau d'interlocuteurs beaucoup plus
d'hommes à hommes au fond de femme à
femme que les décisions soient prises là
où les choses se passent sans avoir à
les renvoyer au niveau régional au
niveau national ça crée des délais sacré
l'incompréhension sacré les moins bonnes
décisions
donc monde en jeu aujourd'hui c'est
d'abord leur côté les bonnes personnes
de les mettre au bon endroit
j'ai un deuxième enjeu c'est de rendre
cette vente publique attractive
aujourd'hui on est on est face à une
situation qui est à certains points
dramatique on a divisé par trois le
nombre de jeunes qui se présentent au
concours depuis 20 ans on a des métiers
qui aujourd'hui n'attire plus mon temps
je sais qu'on va offrir 40 mille stage
en 2021 au jeune français pour qu'ils
voient la réalité des métiers
oui mais c'est ce que le caire va
évoluer le cas où il vous dit il n'y a
pas besoin de fonctionnaires partout
c'est ça qu'il faut aujourd'hui il ya
des choses qui faisaient ça tu sais pas
d'où j'entends que moi même je vous
tiens territoriale est ce que j'entends
dans votre discours notamment sur le
concept de subsidiarité de prendre les
bonnes décisions au bon niveau
à quel moment les collectivités locales
avec la fonction publique territoriale
et il est fonctionnaire sous contrat
pour les agents publics sous contrat
ceux qui ne sont pas sous statut de
fonctionnaires peuvent être un moment
donné aussi acteur de cette
transformation est bon moi j'ai un
échange très
régulier quasiment permanente les
employeurs territoriaux avec les
employeurs territoriaux
nous avons acté que tous les employeurs
publics perret dès 2022 puis 2024 la
mutuelle santé de leurs agents on a des
enjeux de protection sociale dans leur
activité
nous avons acté avec les employeurs
territoriaux que sur l'apprentissage que
sur les stages nous avions tous à donner
à la fosse oblique son rôle d'ascenseur
social d'assurer aux jeunes qu'ils
puissent terminer leurs études ils
puissent valider leur année d'études
dans des personnes dans des périodes
compliquées avec les employeurs
territoriaux je travaille sur
l'apprentissage comment on doit rendre
l'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique pour que ce soit une vraie
filière d'insertion professionnelle moi
mon ange et aujourd'hui c'est d'abord
que quand je recrute les bonnes
personnes étaient bonnes compétences
puissent se présenter ensuite que les
bonnes personnes au bon endroit donc ça
veut dire beaucoup de réallocation de
nos moyens
c'est du bon sens mais pas forcément
tout le monde sous statut public ensuite
ces questions de statut évidemment il
n'y a pas de concours pour être spécial
et du numérique public heureusement que
nous pouvons recruter des personnes avec
des contrats pour venir nous aider sur
les enjeux numériques
il n'y a pas de concours sur un certain
nombre d'enjeux environnementaux parce
que on a aujourd'hui dans les
collectivités des nouveaux projets de
développement qui ne correspondent pas
envoyé alors concours x ore heureusement
qu'on peut donc moi alors heureuse
recruter les bonnes personnes
mais pas forcément son statut fonctions
au quai il faut pas là-dessus avoir deux
totems je défends le statut je pense que
c'est une vraie protection sur la
laïcité sur les principes prévu qu'un
sur la liberté aussi qu'on donne aux uns
et aux autres
mais aujourd'hui alors bien qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui nous demandent
d'ailleurs d'avoir d'autres formes de
contrat et si ça nous rend à 39
il faut qu'on alors là il va y avoir
débat parce que maty de panneaux qui
vous écoutent n'est pas je pense sur
cette longueur hôte aura pas du tout
d'accord 1 en fait c'est un chrono avec
le ministre mais avec le coeur rien que
la crise du covin n'est pas passé par là
parce que quand même c'est tout ce type
de discours qui nous a rendus
complètement impuissant pour faire face
à la pandémie
la gestion gouvernementale de la crise
n'a été qu'une gestion de la pénurie de
lits de test de mass maintenant de
vaccin et surtout deux soignants et
alors on peut parler des cent mille lits
qui ont été fermées en battant on peut
on peut discuter de tout ça mais un
moment quand est ce qu'on va tirer les
bilans de ça et qu'on va dire on va
arrêter de dire qu'on peut faire moins
avec monsieur madame la ministre vous
venez de dire qu'il serait pas de
responsables de dire maintenant qu'on
baisserait le nombre de fonctionnaires
alors c'est pas responsable de le dire
malheureusement vous le faites
gg
j'ai notamment alors j'ai un certain
nombre d un que je vais pour prendre
trois exemples rapidement le premier
j'aimerais que vous réagissiez à ce qui
a été dit dans cash investigations du
décembre 2020 qui révélait une pratique
absolument illégal c'est que pour
compenser les baisses d'effectifs chez
les fonctionnaires
eh bien on embauchait des jeunes en
service civique à 580 euros par mois et
vous donner un exemple par exemple à
pôle emploi un jeune qui faisait alors
réponse ayez de conscience des progrès
pour bien des exemples parce que très
rapidement parce qu'ils sont liés un
décret du 21 mars qui baisse le nombre
de places de magistrats qu'on va pouvoir
recruter dans notre pays alors que vous
le savez vous avez été ministre des
affaires européennes on a déjà deux fois
moins de juges et de montfa moins de
greffier dans notre pays et que donc la
france en manque donc on poursuit la
clochardisation de la justice puisque on
baisse le nombre de magistrats à
recruter ou encore le service public
forestier et là je vais vous dire
maintenant dans le service public profs
et bien nous n'aurons plus d'embaucher
des fonctionnaires mais des contractuels
avec 40% des effectifs qui ont été
baissés et 500 postes qui vont être
supprimés d'ici à 2026 donc moi j'avais
une question c'est est est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas appeler votre front votre
ministère directement ministère de la
liquidation de la fonction publique et
de l'état parce que lorsqu'on liquide
l'expertisé humaine de l'état eh bien on
laisse là encore tout lâche au lobby
pour décider à notre place
déjà 1 sur le service civique j'ai pris
une décision très forte que les
pratiques qui ont été révélées soient
sanctionnés nous avons maintenant une
charte
toutes les personnes qui ne respectent
pas sa charte de ce qu'est le service
civique d'abord un engagement de là je
ne sais pas un piper remplacer la poste
avec l'agencé pour qu'un pc des
effectifs non c'est pas le rôle des
services civiques je peux vous dire
qu'il a été très clairement écrit signé
nous avons pris un engagement très clair
qui est connu me désormais que les
pratiques en question soient absolument
un prohibé deux sanctionnés mais
fonctionne et comment est sanctionné
parce que ça veut dire que les mais
comment comment commencer avec les
ministères perdre leur agrément c'est
ben oui d'accord il n'existe plus avec
les jeunes sont d'accord sortie de
position qui ne correspond pas à leurs
engagements
ça c'est extrêmement important parce
qu'effectivement c'était intolérable de
considérer que dans certains services
publics et bien au lieu de valoriser
l'engagement d'un jeune sa formation son
rôle justement civique et citoyen
l'émission qui était proposée
l'accompagnement ne correspondait pas à
ce que doit être le serviteur
première chose même chose sur les
recrutements nous recrutons aujourd'hui
je peux vous dire il ya 7500 postes
d'infirmières des soignants ouvert dans
la fonction publique hospitalière vient
saluer avons mis 8 milliards d'euros sur
la table pour revaloriser les salaires
les grillons euros dans moins pour les
hôpitaux publics en 2021 c'est le plfss
mais bon c'est alicia l'exposant play 19
milliards d'investissement que nous
avons annoncé un plan de relance pour
l'hôpital les 9 milliards dont mr cap
sur le ségur la revalorisation des
grilles que je porte pour notamment les
biens sur la fonction big hospitalière
mais aussi à face aux bills
territoriales et de l'état
pour ce qui concerne les infirmières
aides soignants nous recrutons et je
vous avoue on va recruter 100 mille
jeunes de moins de 25 ans dans les trois
fonctions publiques cette année
parce que le renouvellement des
générations fait que nous recrutons donc
moi je n'ai aucune aucune difficulté à
vous dire sur l'office national des
forêts parce que bon lui qui avait été
d'accord avec mathilde tanoh sur ce oui
je suis d'accord parce que on a on a
peut progressivement fait un choix de
voir disparaître un certain nombre
d'organismes qui sont d origine le
verticaux héritage pour lui la plupart
d'entre eux de la troisième république
et là on a on a au moment où on va avoir
le plan de relance la chance d'avoir
encore l'ossature de l'onef alors là
vous êtes face à un jeu le gouvernement
face à un choix drastique soit vous êtes
d'accord de l'eau et de l'air
si ce n'est une une erreur est une
hérésie soit ils confortent le modèle de
l'onef quitte à trouver des relais
partenariat important je crois il trouve
que je présidais communes forestières
dans mon département
je connais très bien cette question là
et le partenariat entre les
collectivités locales et le nez je pense
qu'un nouveau modèle à réinventer mais
que cet office je rejoins ce qui a été
dit ce avec quoi je ne suis pas tout à
fait d'accord c'est qu'on n'est pas
obligé d'avoir tous les agents y compris
ouvriers forestiers sous statut
fonctionné alors made in america
aujourd'hui après mathy de panneaux mais
quand même il faut il faut que cette
maison qui est la fierté de la france
via lattea de panneaux je suis d'accord
mais moi je l'étendre à tous les
services publics c'est là c'est
probablement notre désaccord mais quand
même
enfin quatre agents sur dix qui ont
disparu en 30 ans
au delà on demande de nouveau la
suppression de 500 pages vous dirai
juste madame la ministre quand même
qu'on aimerait bien voir l'assemblée qui
demandait le moratoire le gel des
suppressions de postes et juin le 9 à
l'aube 9 aloha nef et bien le
gouvernement est repassé en deux heures
lecture ailleurs nous a refait faire un
deuxième va répondre avant perdre répond
elle réponse demain dimanche à tabor
c'est à dire le qui avait 10 iphone la
fonction publique ne s'occupe que les
sujets régaliens je ne suis pas d'accord
avec cette idée il ya beaucoup de
politiques notamment dans le domaine
environnemental qui demande une
politique piloté stratégique
c'est d'une d'un débat qui a eu lieu au
effectivement parlement c'est le mini je
viens de normandie qui je crois continue
travaille d'ailleurs sur notamment la
levée sur la forêt il ya énormément
d'eau deux ans je continuais de
supprimer des postes en fait c'est ça la
question qu'on pose aujourd'hui cette
discussion elle est le fruit d'un projet
de réorganisation de la manière neutre
avec des collectivités la manière dont
on partage les tâches
évidemment aujourd'hui je vois bien
qu'ils ressemblent contestation qui
n'entendent équilibres ont probablement
une activité d'ailleurs probablement
déquilibre qui va falloir remettre sur
le métier c'est à dire que pour
l'instant rien n'est acté c'est encore
joie de loi qui est acté il ya
effectivement des négociations qui fait
sur le dos de bottes ça pourrait se
jouer
non jacques à n'est pas pour cette année
non en fonction de chaque année vous
avez un projet de loi de finances qui
définit un schéma d'emplois qui définit
un nombre d'emplois sait on est en
démocratie il ya des contestations les
choses sont discutés les choses ensuite
sont assumés bah je vais pas vous faire
la stratégie de la bnf c'est pas dans
mon périmètre
mais je tiens à dire que en pratique ma
vision des choses c'est d'abord de dire
il faut qu'on soit clair sur quels sont
les objectifs politiques puis con con
con poursuis mon objectif ensuite de
positionnement des fonctionnaires c'est
que ce soit le plus possible des agents
opérationnels de teyran que nous
renforcions et que nous arrêtions
d'avoir des ministères centraux ont mis
sur le net
pourtant c'est l'une des postes à
l'honneur mais parce qu'il y avait un
projet de réorganisation qui se pourrait
vous est présenté par le ministre
aujourd'hui la poésie la forêt
d'ailleurs fait partie des également du
plan de relance vous savez qu'on insulte
un plan 13 ans 200 millions 2
d'investissement à la forêt donc on
accompagne ansa je demanderai au
ministre de l'agriculture qui s'en
occupe et la mise l'environnement
évidemment de pouvoir revenir vers vous
avec les détails et la discussion qui
doit s'imposer on est en démocratie
la discussion va continuer discussions
c'est normal mais pas pour cette année
vous avez dit mathilde panos à ses cinq
sens et sur ses terres et les 95 passe
son son acte et de supprimer 95 sur cinq
sens et ça et 95 et 500 jusqu'à 2026
d'accord donc mes affaires en fait du
cabinet simplement parce que juste dans
la loi a zappé on a aussi voté qu'il y
avait plus de fonctionnaires mais des
contractuels ce qui moi me pose un gros
sujet lorsque l'on parle de long terme
avec notamment la question de la forêt
direct de gens sous pression financière
forte on va rejoindre vincent roux au
figaro like bonsoir vincent qu'est ce
que les
internautes vos lecteurs et nos
téléspectateurs ont fait circuler sur le
figaro live bonsoir francis bonsoir
amélie dimanche à l'ats alors ce qui
passionne les internautes du figaro
c'est le la faire autour de l'evergreen
ce cargo qui à bloquer le canal de suez
et parmi les commentaires beaucoup
s'interrogent sur la mondialisation à
outrance
est ce que cette affaire ne posent pas
la question face aux pénuries qui menace
dans ces cas-là de relocaliser les
productions est ce que ça ne souligne
pas les risques de la mondialisation des
sauvages
je crois que le canal de suez il est là
depuis longtemps 56 depuis donc 956 mais
c'est à dire le cardinal le canal
lesseps a fait ça quand même il ya
quinze ans à we have an avant oui
d'accord mais je parlais police et que
évidemment il ya un enjeu on voit bien
de commerce est un enjeu international
dans le plan de relance nous avons une
vision d'une france qui produit une
france productive nous investissons pour
que dans notre pays
à ce moment deux filières stratégiques
pharmaceutiques agricoles sur un
ensemble de composants produisent en
france et en europe
donc évidemment qu'on le voit bien en
ces périodes on l'avait vu un stand
d'autres moments il ya des ruptures de
chaîne de valeur nous devons produire en
france mais on avait juste avant la
crise' qu'ovide recrée vingt mille
enfants industriel recréer vingt mille
endroits industrielle en france c'est
bien parce que nous pensons que nous
avons besoin de produire plus en france
d'un composant pour éviter que vincent
vincent 10 secondes ça vous convient je
remercie la ministre doit avoir rappelé
que le canal de suez existait depuis le
dix neuvième siècle où l'on écrit parce
qu'ils ont été trompés mais entre la
nationalisation et la création
merci merci en tout cas loïc hervé merci
ma type de panneau des venues débattre
avec un mini manche alain sur les sujets
qui concernent la fonction publique mais
aussi bien évidemment de vie quotidienne
parce que la fonction publique ça fait
partie de notre vie quotidienne et merci
à mille îles marshall 1 d'avoir accepté
de participer à l'audition publique
audition publique qui revient dans
quinze jours puisque la semaine
prochaine ce sera un week end un peu
fériés à 19h30 en direct
évidemment bonne soirée et merci
[Musique]